anytime i see the words simple rules as
it pertains to diet
i get a little bit nervous hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be taking a look at lifestyle
youtuber zoe unlimited and everything
she eats while intermittent fasting but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
billbar so if you are a snack queen like
me yes queen you need these bars in your
life i've got a whole pantry of snacks
in my house but i keep these right here
in my office so that i am ready when the
snack attack hits and these honestly
never disappoint so i am super excited
because i just got a box of my all-time
favorite flavor cookie dough chunk if
you know you know if you know you know
so
very excited to dig in
look at that a whole box of goodies yes
[Music]
these ones have legit chunks of cookie
dough in them
like
your mine will be blown
oh it's so good
honestly the flavor is unlike any other
bar so they're made with real chocolate
so they actually taste like a chocolate
bar not like a chalky protein bar but
they are packed with protein which we
love and they're also a lower sugar bar
so when i need a solid complete snack
for like post workout i always try to
pair them with some fruit or toast or
oats so if you want to try these out
yourself check out my link in the
description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
now before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode alright folks
let's get into it intermittent fasting
has been a lifestyle i adopted for
almost two years and has helped me
personally in my weight loss and health
journey to be completely honest with you
i eat pretty much what i want to eat but
there are several roles i follow when
i'm on intermittent fasting i have
discussed my thoughts on intermittent
fasting in my video right here but in
short intermittent fasting is not much
different than other calorically
restrictive diets when it comes
specifically to weight loss but unlike
other diets there are no hard and fast
diet rules with intermittent fasting
asides from when you can eat but rules
are made to be broken in other words
what and how much you eat is basically
free game now while a lot of
intermittent fasting proponents will
talk about the benefits of intermittent
fasting for insulin suppression ketosis
and autophagy the reality is the main
reason why intermittent fasting results
in potential weight loss is because
we're just not so great at making up for
the calories missed in any specific
skipped meal now with that said let's
take a look at some of zoe's rules my
rule number one is to eat enough protein
i always try to make sure that i break
my fast with something filling so i
agree i think protein should ideally be
present in most meals if possible
regardless of whether or not you're
intermittent fasting now this is not
only so important for muscle protein
synthesis but it will also help to
contribute to satiety and blood sugar
regulation which is really why i always
talk about protein with my hunger
crushing combo protein protein protein
protein however protein intake may be
particularly important for intermittent
fasters as research suggests that there
is definitely a risk of muscle loss when
doing an extreme fast now this isn't a
huge deal for most people without
specific body composition goals but for
optimal muscle protein synthesis we
ideally want to be getting in a dose of
protein every three to four hours or so
this obviously is harder to do with
fewer eating episodes so making sure to
optimize each one with a solid amount of
protein is definitely very important now
if something like muscle growth is your
goal then ultimately intermittent
fasting probably isn't ideal since we
now know that most highly active folks
can only utilize about 0.25 to 0.4 grams
of protein per kilogram of body weight
for protein muscle synthesis
what bro what are you talking about for
example eating like a 60 gram protein
meal isn't going to be the same for your
body as eating two doses of 30 grams of
protein but i'd say for the average
person without these goals i don't
really think it's a huge deal for my
rule number two
eat enough greens as you probably have
noticed no matter if a fruit or veggie
i'd like to include some fiber into my
meal athletic greens is a comprehensive
formula packed with 75 vitamins minerals
and whole food source ingredients i
drink it regularly like a juice or blend
it with my greek yogurt okay so let's
talk about the rule first like i said
with protein regardless of whether or
not you're interested in fasting we
should really all be aiming to meet our
daily fiber recommendations and while
leafy greens do provide fiber and
micronutrients they are also very low in
calories and given that intermittent
fasting shortens your eating window
significantly i would really want to
make sure that every single eating
opportunity is optimized nutritionally
and calorically and while it is great to
have veggies represented in most meals
we definitely want to ensure that
they're complemented by a source of
protein fat and carbs we also want to
aim to get our fiber intake from a
variety of sources so we get a nice
balance of insoluble and soluble fiber
now i'm oversimplifying here but in very
quick short insoluble fiber is largely
for regularity satiety and cancer
prevention and soluble fiber is usually
for things like cholesterol and blood
sugar management gut health and satiety
so as always variety is key this is a
major key alert ask for a supplement
like athletic greens i get asked all the
time to review these types of
supplements and whether or not they
actually will replace actual real fruits
and vegetables so first of all they are
third party tested which obviously you
guys know i like so for folks who really
struggle to meet their micronutrient
needs through food i do see this as like
a potential drinkable multivitamin but
for folks who already get in a nice
variety of veggies and fruit in their
day it's ultimately unnecessary and if
fiber is your rationale for getting in
your greens in the first place which it
does sound like that's the case for zoe
it's not actually the best source like a
serving here has less than two grams of
fiber i also don't love that we don't
know how much of each ingredient we're
getting in some of their proprietary
blends here but again i don't think
these supplements are harmful and they
may actually be helpful for the right
person but for zoe who's already getting
in some fruits and veggies i would way
rather see her not take up valuable
stomach real estate with such a low
calorie drink eat enough probiotics i
generally like to always keep my fridge
stocked with greek yogurt while there is
no strong association or link between
probiotics intermittent fasting
specifically there is some research to
suggest that taking probiotics while
intermittent fasting can have some
psychological benefits like improved
social functioning and mental well-being
however it is currently unclear if these
positive effects are independent of
intermittent fasting in other words you
may likely experience these same
benefits even if you're not fasting
since probiotics are associated with
improvements in mood thanks to of course
the amazing gut brain connection now
research also suggests that probiotics
may help to support regularity immunity
and even heart health honestly there's
lots of fantastic emerging research on
our gut so i'm gonna keep you guys all
up to date as i get some more of that
information now as for zoe her probiotic
source of choice is yogurt which i think
is an excellent option because you know
you're getting in that protein calcium
vitamin d maybe some fat in there
depending on you know that percentage
however keep in mind that food sources
of probiotics like yogurt often do not
provide a clinical dose of a probiotic
strain so to be specific to be
considered a probiotic yogurt the
serving size must contain a minimum of 1
billion cfus however this is not
considered a therapeutic dose and has
far less than probiotic supplements
which would usually have upwards of 10
to 50 billion cfus ultimately though i
would say yogurt is a super nutritious
food so assuming there's no intolerances
there's no downside to including these
types of foods in your diet i say every
little bit helps this last roll i follow
when intermittent fasting and that is to
enjoy
what i'm eating yes queen yes queen so
this should be rule
number one in my books now interestingly
there is even research to suggest that
you may actually absorb more nutrients
from food that you actually enjoy so one
study found that participants absorbed
nearly 50 percent more nutrients from
the food that they enjoyed and 70
percent less iron from the same food
when it was prepared in a way that made
it less appealing in other words same
food less nutrient absorption when it
wasn't actually enjoyed again that brain
gut connection is really the closest
thing that i know of to magic in the
nutrition world
very good all right
as i always say there's no point choking
down a green smoothie or like an egg
white omelet if you are totally
miserable for it because not only is it
potentially less nutritious for you but
it's also typically a set up for a binge
so now that we have a sense of zoe's
diet rules let's take a look at some of
her meals went for a green onion pancake
plus sunny side up eggs zoe typically
breaks her fast around noon and eats a
wide variety of meals which you know we
love to see so aside from her green
onion pancake she also enjoys dumplings
with a side of sauteed spinach a ham and
cheese croissant seaweed soup pollock
burger with sauteed cabbage a veggie
scramble as well as a cheeseburger and
sausage now as per her protein rule
she'll usually pair her meals with a
small portion of yogurt and fruit chia
pudding a glass of soy milk a protein
shake or some boiled eggs so in her
green onion pancake meal she's got
protein from the eggs greek yogurt and
the chia pudding plus some fat in the
eggs in the pudding and fiber-rich carbs
in the fruit and pancake and it's a
solid meal around 750 calories i'd say
which would be the minimum of what i'd
want to see when we're only having two
to three eating episodes or
opportunities in the day i also see a
few of her other rules at play in this
meal so we've got a little probiotic
action from the yogurt some fiber from
the fruit and chia pudding a little
green i guess in the pancake if you want
to count scallions and most importantly
she also seems to be really enjoying her
meal if i was to give her any kind of
gentle nutrition tip it would be to
maybe throw in some sauteed spinach or
really anything any leftover vegetables
that she has in the fridge to that
delicious looking green onion pancake
but also it looks so good i don't blame
her for not wanting to change it i ate a
coconut milk bar as a snack for extra
protein before dinner okay so as far as
snacks are concerned we only get to see
one snack for this week which was a
protein bar and this is obviously a
great choice because like i said it will
help to optimize protein absorption
between our meals now you guys know i
love build bars because full disclosure
i work with them
i would want to see this bulked up into
a bit of a meal by pairing it with a
source of carbs since again build bars
are a lower sugar bar and also
relatively lower in calories as well now
aside from this one day zoe's typically
going like six hours between meals and
doing a 17 to 18 hour fast aka the 16 8
method now ultimately if this way of
eating feels good to zoe great but i
just want to highlight that women's
bodies tend to be more sensitive to
caloric restriction and may therefore be
more vulnerable to adverse side effects
like hormonal imbalances irregular
periods and infertility with these more
aggressive fasting protocols so we'll
have to see how things stack up
nutritionally for zoe later on in the
video but for now let's just take a
quick look at some of her dinner meals
tofu shrimp spinach
and the veggie pack
add some green onions and sesame and
voila
love me a stir fry dinner because it's
such an intuitive way to create a hunger
crushing combo and switch it up based on
just what you have on hand so in this
case we've got some protein from the
eggs tofu and shrimp we got fat in the
oil carbs from the noodles and some
fiber from the spinach and dehydrated
veg now other than this stir-fry dish
similar to our breakfast meals zoe
enjoys a wide variety of dinner meals
including stir fried ground beef with
broccoli baked chicken or salmon with a
side of vegetables like zucchini or
shiitake mushrooms cabbage soup with
tofu and fish as well as a braised duck
gizzard now her dinner meals are usually
paired with a small serving of brown
rice or chia pudding and will often
include more than one source of protein
so for example she paired her ground
beef stir fry with a ready egg and our
cabbage soup with tofu and fish
beautiful variety and all super
satiating meals though i would say a
little bit low in carbs when compared to
her portions of protein i'm not sure if
that's intentional or she just likes
variety but still i would recommend she
may want to try to balance that out a
little bit so now let's talk about my
overall thoughts on zoe's intermittent
fasting diet first of all i have to say
that usually when i hear intermittent
fasting and rules in the same sentence i
automatically
cringe expecting some kind of
restrictive pseudoscience protocol to
become in my way so the fact that zoe's
rules simply emphasize how to optimize
meals in a balanced and varied way while
also prioritizing enjoyment of food is a
huge huge relief they're also super
simple and accessible rules that can be
easily implemented every day regardless
of whether or not you're intermittent
fasting as for the meals themselves i
love the variety in the week and the
inherent balance that we've got going on
not to mention the obvious love that she
puts into her food this video made me
really really hungry and also totally
inspired having said that it's just not
enough
with just two eating episodes in the day
zoe's only eating around 1100 calories
on average which is likely about half of
what she needs she's also getting just
over half of her fiber needs and isn't
getting a ton of carbs in general well i
love the variety of protein sources and
i agree on her rule that protein is very
important we also don't want to be
displacing everything else so my gentle
nutrition recommendation for zoe would
be to add in another meal and reduce her
fasting window to no more than 14 hours
max to make it easier for her to get
that nutrition in i get that she may
have weight loss goals but i do worry
about the metabolic and hormonal
outcomes of this aggressive fasting
regimen this would also just make the
diet more accessible and sustainable in
the long run as well as in this video
she did mention having to deny eating at
an event because it went past 6 p.m and
in another video of hers that i watched
she even expresses how hard it is to
miss out on social events because of
intermittent fasting so i'm really
hoping that in the future she's able to
find a more flexible approach to her
eating that helps her meet her goals
feel her best but not miss out on life
in other words my diet prescription for
zoe would be less rules more life which
is probably a mantra we can all benefit
from living by in some way and on that
note that's all that i have for you guys
today thanks again to billbar for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who you'd like seeing
your view next subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]